all right many of you been have been
asking questions related to the
financial fallout from the corona virus
pandemic CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger joins us with some answers
Jill good morning welcome back thanks
let me start you off with the first
question which comes from Jim who writes
that his workplace is closed but his
employer has not communicated
communicated what his job status is at
this point so he's wondering should he
file for unemployment absolutely don't
wait and I think it's fair to say that
anyone who has been sidelined more than
a week and you haven't heard from your
boss just presume you're unemployed
remember the cares Act that was passed a
few weeks ago it expands eligibility for
unemployment so go ahead make that claim
and bring your patients with you because
it's going to take a while in many
states to get those unemployment claims
moving so as soon as possible please do
that Jill I've got a good question from
Andrea she says her family's income is
inconsistent they have a mortgage loans
and credit card bills and she wants to
know which one should she prioritize
it's so important to do this I think
that for anyone who has any income at
all or even those who have been laid off
or furloughed looking at those expenses
and prioritizing those bills really a
number one job so here's a great tip you
can go to consumerfinance.gov that's the
CFPB website they've got a prioritizing
build tool on the site you'll note that
of course food comes first but
everything after that is negotiable you
may say I've got to make my car payment
because you know what I need to drive to
work or you may say I don't need my car
right now I'm going to tell my but the
the lender that I need some help
regardless go through this exercise
prioritize your bill for those bills
that you cannot pay reach out to the
lenders reach out to landlords ask for
some help say the virus has impacted you
many are willing to cut you some slack
Jill our viewer Andrea says her
family's income is inconsistent they
have a mortgage loans and credit card
bills she asked how oh sorry we asked
that question forgive me I want I want
to go to question from Bob Bob says I am
67 I was planning on retiring next year
what should people who are approaching
retirement be doing right now I have
gotten this message probably a thousand
times on my podcast and it the they're
coming in Fast and Furious the thing is
that as you approach retirement you
would have hoped that you came into the
period with some lower risk in some of
your assets maybe you'd have not as much
money in your retirement plan in the
stock market but a lot of people just
found out that they whoops made a
mistake so now what do you do you go
back and you start running your numbers
for your own retirement planning if you
need help there's a lot of resources
online but what you want to make sure is
that you've got enough money to create
the income you need and if you need to
work longer they meant that might not be
the most ideal scenario but it actually
might help you really get through this
period because if you can go back to
work work for an extra year that you
hadn't planned on that may allow you to
not invade your retirement assets at a
time when markets are still trading a
lot lower than they were just a month
and a half ago Jill this question comes
from Stacey who's in a position I think
a lot of workers are she writes that
she's getting a 10% pay cut until
further notice and she wants to know if
she should consider lowering her 401k
contributions you know I think it is a
tough decision it really depends how
close you were living to the edge if you
were putting money into your retirement
plan comfortably and you can still do
that it would be great if you could
continue and here is why when you have
retirement contributions automatically
coming out of your paycheck those
contributions happen regardless of
whether the market is up or down imagine
this you're buying shares lower so if
possible hold on keep putting that money
away and try not to mess with your game
plan
all right Jill Schlesinger many thanks